were you a child star
before
the original full house
uh i did a lot of commercials and stuff
when i was young before full house i
really full house was one of my first
big television gigs i did uh
i don't know if you remember the show
the hogan family yeah
uh i actually did a guest appearance on
the hogan family as
pamela poole who was mrs poole the next
door neighbor's niece
and it was an episode where she was
watching me and then she like throws her
back out or something and then jason
bateman and
um
the other two jeremy licht and uh danny
i can't remember his last name anyway
they take over wind up babysitting me
but that was my very first tv role i was
four and a half and it was the same
producers uh that were doing full house
the same executive producers miller
boyet and they loved what i did and they
cast me on full house from that i never
actually auditioned for the show i
basically did a guest appearance on
valerie and they were like this is who
we want for stephanie
i was incredibly lucky and before that i
got to do i did a
sizzler commercial that was really
successful like the ad company wound up
giving me a dog when i was like four
because the the commercial was so
successful and it was like i kind of got
i gave you a dog they gave me because
like it was bbc they gave me a dog
because the it did so well and because
originally
they had a boy cast for the part and
they brought me in as a backup and i did
it and they and this poor little boy had
to just stand to the side all day
while they completely changed the entire
commercial to be a daughter they didn't
even have a name for me so they just
used jody like i mean it was
yeah and and it was a sizzler
all-you-can-eat shrimp commercial and it
was a really hugely popular
thing so television commercials have
always been like a really like
good paying thing right a good national
commercial is awesome like you know
people that when you see like those
people in commercials that are doing
that you know the the
whatever the insurance one progressive
all that [ __ ] right they i mean
they're they're doing great off of
something
i had a buddy that did a zima commercial
and he got picked up and he made like 90
grand off of it yeah you make a ton off
of
national commercials i don't know how it
is now i mean the business is so
different now from when i started like
it's just vastly different but if it's
based on impressions i would imagine
that it's still very lucrative yes well
i mean now you know if the instagram fee
all that [ __ ] is just basically can i
say that
i was like if i can't say the word [ __ ]
on stevo's podcast i don't know what
kind of planet i'm living on
um but yeah it's you know it that was my
introduction into it and i was four
years old and then by five i was working
on full house and then that was oh [ __ ]
you were five when full house started
yeah
i was four and a half when i did valerie
and then i got cast i was five years old
i pictured you as like the older sister
no
candace was ten
i was five and then ashley mary kate
were nine months old
damn
yeah it shows how much i know
[ __ ] what's that like walking onto a set
at five like i mean at that point do you
even know what's going on oh yeah i was
i it was funny i actually just today i
ran into
um joel zwick who directed
tons of episodes of full house the
original i met him when i was four and a
half years old
uh he directed our pilot i've known him
forever ran into him randomly today but
he still talks about he's like at five
years old like you
sat at the table reading table you read
that script with everybody else like you
were on it you had everybody laughing at
five i could read a little before my
third birthday
unbelievable yeah did you like that
attention i'm kind of i'm a little bit
of a nerd and and so yeah i've loved
reading my whole life dude i was on an
airplane recently and i watched an hbo
documentary about child stars
and it was like
kind of pretty dark like the whole there
was an indictment of like you know
pushing kids into show business right
which i you know it's unfortunate well
it's not it isn't it isn't i guess my
experience was so vastly different
growing up in this business
like
yes there are some things that
come along with
being famous at a young age yeah but my
overall experience was so wonderful and
positive and like i have this family of
people 35 years later
that i'm still friends with and like
still
are my family
i never experienced any abuse my parents
always were like if this isn't what you
love
we're not gonna make you do it it was
never my parents idea like i wanted to
does a four-year-old say i want to go on
an audition yeah really wow i was bet
when i was three years old i told my mom
i would watch tv and i'd say mommy i
want to be a modeler which was the
people that i saw on tv
and she was like i don't i mean i don't
know like my parents were very hesitant
i mean my dad
had you know he was a superintendent of
a gypsum plant in long beach harbor my
mom was a stay-at-home mom of a wet
plant a gypsum plant drywall oh wow i've
never heard i don't think i've ever
heard the word gypsum yeah it's like a
drywall union
uh it's like electrician plumber
i don't know i mean
maybe
i think it falls under like dock workers
or something i don't know but my dad you
know had a very blue collar job he was a
handyman all my life
um my mom was a stay homeless huh and
you were in los angeles we were in uh
like lakewood was where we first lived
which is technically l.a county but
pretty far south kind of next to long
beach
and uh so my mom put me in dance classes
and like you know at the my first
recital i was in the second row and
apparently i thought the girl in front
of me was just [ __ ] it all up so i
like kind of pushed her out and i was
like i got this
and like what you know my mom was like
i mean maybe she should perform she
really loves it right and i did i i came
alive and still to this day i i don't
think i ever feel more
at home then when i'm on set working
like having all of that going on it just
feels like
totally comfortable to me and i never
stopped you know what
in high school i stopped wanting to
audition as much and my mom was like all
right cool like this isn't what you want
to do i'm not going to drive you around
everywhere and
want it for you
and i took some time off i went to
performing arts high school and i was it
so
it was always my idea though and i
didn't have a terrible experience
but i know
so many people have because and i've
seen it i've seen parents that want it
more than their kids right
that's interesting to say
in high school i didn't want to audition
anymore where
you think of child stars and and the
dynamic that's sort of like kind of dark
and said like maybe when they grow up a
little bit people don't find them cute
anymore and then they're sort of like
maybe like 12 years old and feeling all
washed up kind of a thing i mean it was
definitely an adjustment at you know at
13 years old i was
finishing middle school which is just
[ __ ] for anyone you know i mean middle
school just kind of sucks right
i have two kids that are going my one is
in eighth grade and one is going into
sixth grade and it's just the most
awkward time of your life right yeah so
i finished the show and i'm starting
high school
so it was just i mean
that time of your life when you're like
who the [ __ ] am i you know like
what what do what do i want what am i
doing and i went to a the orange county
high school for the arts i was in
musical theater okay so i still had that
performing outlet
and i did party of five i did a few i
did like a
six episode guest starring thing on
party five when i was a little bit older
and i thought you're gonna say i did
party my ass off
because i did i mean i did but that was
like later in my you know right like
high school and and 20 is when i really
acted like an [ __ ] were you still
going to grade school while you were
filming mm-hmm they didn't like by law
you didn't have like a teacher on set i
had both our producers again really
wanted
were really
involved and engaged in how the kids on
the show were doing
so i really wanted to go to regular
school in the morning and because we
lived in orange county and like traffic
sucked getting up there at eight
we worked it out to where i think my
first season i did
my school on set just because we were
kind of getting into the groove of it
but after that like i went to school in
the morning we worked 40 weeks so monday
i was at school all day
tuesday wednesday i went to school until
lunch and then got picked up and
thursday and friday i did my work on set
so i had like
a foot in normal life and i just went to
a public school in orange county
normal life like i didn't live some
crazy you know yes i got to do really
cool [ __ ] growing up you know but i also
lived a very
normal grounded life and i think that
that
really helped me
be a halfway normal [ __ ] person you
know what i mean like so if my math is
right you were 13 when you stopped doing
full house you were five when it started
so it ran for eight years eight years we
did eight seasons of that show yeah and
five seasons of fuller house for netflix
and so that means it's super syndicated
like did you get to renegotiate your
contract after like so many years and
get like back end and stuff
you don't get back-end stuff but you
still get you know some residuals but
residuals people think they're you know
you're making like hundreds of thousands
of dollars you're like it's look it's a
nice little bonus of like i can put a
little bit of money aside maybe or pay
my bills with it but it's not
not everything that everyone thinks it
is you know and now with
netflix and streaming like again like i
said the business is so different like
residuals aren't a thing anymore right
you get paid out up front they pay you
far less than you know they used to on
network shows
and you get paid out and that's it like
you'll get maybe dvd sales and stuff
like that but it's it's a very different
business than it used to be but yeah i
mean look full house has been on the air
ever since it started in 1986 it's never
been
not on the air somewhere in the world so
that's crazy it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude